Sometimes, though, the equation of a circle won't appear in this form. It could
appear like this. When we see an equation with an x squared term, a y squared
term, and other terms that have x and y at a constant, we want to re-arrange
this so we can put it in this form. Notice that we have a perfect square of an
x term, and a perfect square of a y term. If this is the case, we want to
re-arrange this equation so we can group the x terms together and we can group
the y terms together. We'll also want to move this constant to the right hand
side of our equation. We do this so that we can complete the square for the x
terms and for the Y terms. So what do we need to add to the left hand side of
our equation to complete the square for these X terms. Keep in mind if we add
an amount to this side we need to add the same amount to the right hand side of
our equation so we keep the equation balanced. And, what do you think we would
need to the y terms in order for this to become a perfect square. Again,
whatever we add to the left, we need to add to the right.